Вчені гадають, як життя на землі трапилось.
Остання така сильна теорія є,
що глина була каталізатором.
Що саме наявність води,
сонця і поверхні глини
було тим самим пусковим механізмом,
з якого почалося життя.
Це починалося 25 років тому.
Тут жила моя прабабуся.
Вона робила квіти з паперу.
Тут була невеличка, глинобитна хатинка,
і з неї починалася моя майстерня.
Ми почали тут щось робити,
і от за всі ці роки побудували декілька будівель.
Приїжджають багато груп,
з інших міст приїжджають,
особливо коли канікули,
то дітей багато приїжджає,
а так і дорослі теж приїзджають групами.
Кожного дня ми проводимо майстер-класи,
можна просто відпочити.
— Вам сподобалось ліпити?
— Так!
— Скажіть, а гончарем хтось стане, коли виросте?
А хто стане? Руку підійміть.
Значить сподобалось, ну добре.
Якщо брати дітей, що приїжджають поліпити,
подивитися, то приблизно дві-три тисячі на рік.
А якщо таких, хто став гончарем, —
десь до десяти.
Так, щоб професійна діяльність, як учні.
Люди, які починали тут, працювали в цій майстерні,
потім мали свої якісь проєкти.
Це наша велика дров'яна піч.
Наскільки мені відомо, вона —
найбільша в Україні,
яка опалює кераміку на дровах.
Кожного разу, коли ми заповнюємо піч роботами,
ми кладемо цеглини і робимо стіну,
замуровуємо її
і починаємо опал із нижніх отворів.
А потім переходимо на оці колосники.
Дрова закидуємо через бокові отвори.
Після цього ми робимо витримку в чотири години
з найвищою температурою,
і піч починає охолоджуватись сама по собі.
Десь через п'ять днів відкриваємо
і достаємо вже готову кераміку.
Січеславська область цікава тим,
що кераміка в нашому регіоні
має дуже смачну форму — класну.
Вона без декору, візерунків.
Дві-три смужки — це максимум.
Це саме та кераміка, яка мені завжди подобалась,
і я намагаюся саме таку кераміку робити.
Я полюбив на дотик.
Коли до рук потрапила справжня гончарна глина,
не ліпити було вже важко.
Усі нормальні студенти, коли я вчився, прогулювали лекції,
щоб піти на пиво, на футбол — хто куди.
А я завжди у свій вільний час ліпив.
Мабуть, мені хотілося з самого початку
мати зручну майстерню,
спілкуватися з людьми, щось створювати
і допомогати іншим щось створювати.
Я взагалі фанат архітектури —
не тільки сучасної.
Ця центральна балка,
яка тримає кровлю, пролягає рівно
з півночі на південь,
і кут її нахилу дорівнює куту нахилу сонця
під час зимового сонцестояння.
Сюди не потрапляє жарке сонце влітку,
а взимку — навпаки.
Завдяки цьому куту нахилу
сонце зимове заходить сюди,
і температура в сонячний зимовий день
піднімається одразу на чотири градуси.
Це дуже багато.
Якщо перераховувати на енергоносії,
то це десь відсотків сорок
йде менше на опалювання.
Такі великі майстерні, де багато гончарних кіл,
де можна навчатись...
Я вперше побачив саме у Шанхаї.
У нас ще такого ніде ні у кого не було.
Взагалі там все масштабне відбувається,
і мене це дуже змотивувало.
Я подумав: «Клас, треба теж таке робити!»
І привіз звідти одинадцять
гончарних кругів.
Сьогодні, здається, така кількість
і є найбільшою в Україні.
У 2014 році, коли почалася ця війна,
то в мене були якісь накопичення,
і я вирішив усі ці гроші залишити тут.
Я вирішив почати масштабне будівництво цієї майстерні.
Мені здалося, що це найкорисніше,
що я можу зробити в цій ситуації.
По-перше, це вилікувало мене і
найближче оточення від депресії.
Люди почали щось будувати.
Відчував, наче це мій обовязок
перед цим місцем, де я народився.
Якщо, десь щось страшне,
то воно тут і залишиться.
Якшо буде все непогано,
то теж все буде добре.
І справді трішки легше стало
переживати ті події.
Це вже готовий.
Майстерня трохи нагадує
Сонячну систему: є певне ядро в центрі,
і навколо нього комети, планети, астероїди,
що наближаються, віддаляються.
Тобто багато людей, які колись працювали,
а зараз, можливо, мають іншу роботу,
приходять, допомагають,
інколи майстер-класи проводять.
Постійно тільки ми з дружиною працюємо.
Броумівський рух.
В мене є глибока впевненість,
що навчити гончарувати — не можна.
Людина сама має навчитися.
Ти тільки можеш дати можливість,
дати умови для того, щоб людина могла
прийти до тебе, побачити, як ти це робиш.
Ти можеш відповісти на якісь питання,
ці питання мають з'явитися у людини.
Коли відбувається така модель навчання,
то у людини складається враження,
що це вона сама навчилася.
Вона це більше цінує.
Я пишаюся усіма, хто тут був.
Особливо тими,
хто має вже свої майстерні.
Мене це тішить, це класно.